das wasser hat vorjahr
murat ernsthaft herzlich willkommen bei
sallys welt eine teilgarantie minuten
rein machst du allein die frau ist
übrigens heute auch im wald bleibt hier
bitte so also folgendes problem haben
wir jetzt gerade sally macht kann man es
ja hallo das ist genau das sei hier
kanal
ich wollte mir nur folgendes sie hat
karten kuchen in der im kühlschrank zum
abkühlen
ich muss die kinder um 17 uhr zum
hip-hop kennen ja ich wünsche mir eine
topmodel angespuckt ja ob ich genug
nicht schluss nicht anspruch so und dann
um 17 uhr haben die kinder hip hop und
ich gehe mit den zum tanzen hat sowie
den zwei kindern unterwegs immer so
machen
das verhängnis und jetzt habe ich
richtig gut da wie nie unterwegs oben
wir sind gerade auch ein bahn
beschäftigt und wir haben heute nirgends
gegessen aus kassenwart ja auf jeden
fall ich brauch jetzt hier nebenbei es
muss schnell gehen
und du kannst hier hinten etwas
rumkommen machen und eher nein ich mir
an apple hier unten machen irgendwas
mach ich weiter putzen naja passau und
zwar putz ist gutes stichwort
und zwar fangen wir an mit den zutaten
ok wollen das kann man
bist du drauf ich habe hier
tom ist drauf aha okay das ist wepper
schwarz ungemein wichtig immer ungemein
petterweil gemahlener pfeffer hat keine
erhoben werden kann es sein dass
plädiert die zutaten vorstellung schon
fünf minuten geht ja was auch hass
bringen nicht die einander ich muss
schnell machen und zwar dass ich seit
meiner seite stehen da haben ja chili
die haben auch hier
dann haben wir hier schlug nudeln
vielleicht schupfnudeln aus kartoffeln
gemacht genau lift veganer durch das
russische ist ein maler ist wohl alles
drin und wenn ihr wollt dass ich die
euch zeigt die warnstufen selber macht
dann schreibt ja genau ich glaube damit
wir dann haben wir 150 milliliter wasser
300 die kommst du 150 java
das ist beide male mandl genau wir
müssen beim wasser schauen da sind es
300 milliliter wasser hast hast du gut
aufgepasst ein esslöffel öl 500 gramm
hackfleisch als rinder hackfleisch 100
gramm schmandt korea also lautet man
kann nämlich anfangen genau was noch gut
passt ja was passt doch sally thymian
rosmarin genau hat sich die stadt jetzt
einfach ok du scheißt in laucha mussten
noch eher schwachen schatz nein und zwar
macht bei den so ich habe jetzt da schon
die dunklen die dunkelgrünen blättern
okay weil die nämlich bitter sind ja und
jetzt nimmst du den laufpass schneide
stehen erst mal in den ring
genau wie schneider nach denen sie und
dann kann man ihnen waschen und so kommt
dann eben auch allesamt rückstände aus
ich tun derzeit schon mal wieder so lang
war
nein die falle ein brennendes öl in die
pfanne und bis fleisch anbraten und zwar
für hier das olivenöl 1 el olivenöl
alles klar
dann haben wir hier hakt gleich von zwei
hackfleisch vom rind warum kommt er in
celle
weil du kein schwein ist genau wenn ihr
mich fragt ob es hier ein ganz ganz
wieso ich sagen jetzt vergessen
und ja da haben wir hier den waka waka
und dann den herd vor hitze stellen ja
und das fleisch anbraten ja er hat auch
hohe hitze und fleisch anbraten und
nehme ich hier diesen weg um in der
wyker theilig dieses fleischhacker wie
ein propeller wahnsinns macht ist keine
erfindung das ist meine erfindung auf
das wirklich niemand anders kommen ok
jetzt brennt das fleisch an
das gerät ist welt an das fleisch brät
anja optimal und nicht immer mit dem
lauch so dass man immer ganz viele
steine drin
und jetzt tue ich das hier rein in so
einer salatschleuder dann kommt direkt
wasser drauf da kann man nämlich den
auch mit dem wasser schleudern und dann
entfernt wo die steine
ja und danach kann man das wasser raus
schleudern man ist nicht so recht und es
war sie auch anhand der zentrifugalkraft
wahnsinn brutal spinnen gegeistert
hauptschule physik leistungskurs achte
klasse weil ich habe es nur wissen
zufolge macht das ist eine ganz tolle
geschichte wenn es zu viel macht hat man
automatisch auch ein springbrunnen
das ist toll wahnsinn weil zu viel
wasser
ja das war natürlich groß jetzt hat mich
auch einst auch gemacht wasser
verschwendet sinnlos weil wir nicht sind
braucht man viel weniger wasser als
normal waschen für alles ein bisschen
aufgeregt ist bei mir versteht warum
wieso redet wie ein roboter so richtig
redet ganz normalen nein das ist ganz
komisch diese roboter doch normal wieder
monat okay du redest roboterstimme die
hat mich ganz vage sind also ich mache
eine frau ganz wahnsinnig das habe ich
jetzt so gesagt aus der stadt kam gesamt
raus ja jetzt wasser weg
[Musik]
jetzt sind wir soweit mit dem
hackfleisch was man wie jetzt ich hab
schon kurz bist der fleischsaft weg ist
ja und zwar muss der schaft erst mal weg
er muss nicht gebraucht wirst du scharf
anbraten hackfleisch sei ja und jetzt
machen wir die laupheimer wird auch
diesen lauf werden im hacker zu erwecken
ok jetzt hat schon richtig cool geruch
und zweitens wie auch im fleisch was man
als nächstes soll würzen bisher kannte
ja und zwar nicht hier schon ein rezept
diese pink geräte zack zack zack zack
gibt's ja auch in schwarz ja gott sei
dank
jetzt kann ich die schupfnudeln mit rein
und einen rosmarin stengel ist ein
schwäbisches was wir jetzt gerade machen
wenn du das doch sagt ja dass man da
kann man ja jetzt auch wenn man möchte
nudeln dazu geben hackfleisch lauchsuppe
ist auch die übrige hackfleisch die
schupfnudeln olivenöl einige schon
nichts besonderes wasser chronische oder
das tattoo ja auf jeden fall etwas ganz
ganz schnell ich würde auch sagen
kostengünstigen ja auf jeden fall
nochmals rein können natürlich auch
berührt verwenden hier das hackfleisch
schreibt übrigens fast schon schick nein
halt nicht geschafft ein von der spieler
da oben geholt einfach aus dem schrank
papa kannst du schon sein
nein so nicht einfach aufkochen genau
ist dass man es einfach aufkochen
[Musik]
es ist mal wieder weg bleiben ja ich
wollte ja auch eigentlich causa macher
autos hätten statt ihre roboter
ich möchte einfach nicht weiß bin in
meinem leben wenn ich so sagen - alleine
ist das böse ist hätte ich mal ich hab
nichts gegen dich wirklich aber du wohl
auch hier aber wenn die jungstars
anderes da kann man dann sagen wir
nichts sagte meine frau da ist oder tom
ja mein teller zu essen und es ist als
sei mache ihn darüber da da da rein
oder willst dazu habe ich will schon
einmal dass das cremig wird so gute
jungs jetzt gelacht teams gelacht
der findet sie ja auch das dach drauf
ruft mich einfach wenn du fertig bist du
warst doch ich mache etwas falsch noch
robin jetzt römer das rum und das essen
das geht jetzt an der kündigung dann
alex und dann mich da kannst du deinen
job machen ok ok ich hab' ich hab auch
ich auch bisher ja und selbst probiert
er spaß und zwar
[Musik]
nachdem die speisekarte so schmeckt
super wirklich ja nur ein bisschen
weniger temperatur aber springen ich
klasse die schupfnudeln die kleben auch
so schön am gaumen ja auch immer
schmeckt lecker ist das mitbringen von
alex war schön dass du mir assistiert
hast aber ich mache es nicht mehr
das ist assistiert wird mit gps schreibt
man das mit drei es existiert ja auf
jeden fall dankeschöns toll mit ihr habe
ich schon mit dir mal ne pizza kuchen zu
backen
du bist wirklich hinter der kamera genau
wieder vor der kamera würde ich mal
sagen und und ich gehe das verstehe ich
glaube es wird uns
[Musik]
seid ihr bereit weihnachtsbäckerei für
kinder heute bin ich nicht auf der suche
nach dem perfekten back ergebnis sondern
nach dem perfekten backtag für die
kinder alles was das kinderherz höher
schlagen lässt schneemänner mäuse und
rentiere ganz wenige zutaten und richtig
coole wer kommt süße weihnachten kam
einfach sally am dritten advent um 16
uhr